Peter Thiel gave an impressive speech
yesterday at the Bitcoin conference now
Peter Thiel he's been talking about
digital currencies for a long time his
speech started off literally with a
video of him almost 20 years ago talking
about an internet currency Peter went on
to found PayPal and ultimately has been
thinking about these ideas for decades
and so to have him speak at the Bitcoin
conference was pretty cool he started
out talking about the complexity of what
is money he then went on to even talk
about many of bitcoin's critics and
talked about the fact that people like
Warren Buffett Jamie Diamond or Larry
Fink they just don't get it but
ultimately the thing that caught my
attention in Peter's speech was he said
don't compare Bitcoin to Gold yes it may
act like digital gold in the beginning
but his thought process is that Bitcoin
eventually could reach the equivalence
with public equities now Bitcoin today
is just under a trillion dollars public
equities are about 115 trillion and as
he went Slide by Slide by slide what you
realize is that Peter Thiel thinks
Bitcoin has a potential 1 100x upside
that one day Bitcoin could reach market
cap parity with equities that is an
incredible point of view coming from one
of the most famous investors in the
world the real competitor for you know
Bitcoin is not ethereum that's a payment
system it's not you know it's not even
gold
it's it's something like the S P 500
it's the stock market as a whole and
this is the way you know this is the way
Bitcoin trades every day you know is the
stocks go up Bitcoin goes up now it's
like a highly levered nasdaq's talk on a
day-to-day basis and that is sort of in
a sense the real competitor and the
question is um
whether we're headed towards a kind of
1970s style world where it's higher
inflation more regulation
um and um and even being you don't want
to be in a stock or Bond but even being
sorry you don't want to be in cash or
Bond but even being in a stock you're
effectively
um in something that's like a
government-linked entity companies woke
companies are sort of quasi-controlled
by the government in a way that Bitcoin
never will be and uh in that sort of a
world
um
I I would submit that perhaps the way we
should think of the Bitcoin to equity
rate you know the Benchmark for Bitcoin
Is Not Gold but equities and the
question is why can't there be parity
between Bitcoin and equities why
shouldn't we be talking about something
more like a hundred to one
which of course won't be won't be as
good as it sounds because um the Fiat
money will be worth a lot less and it'll
be taxed pretty heavily and and whatnot
but I think um but I'm still hopeful
that if uh Bitcoin goes up by a factor
of 100 you will uh you'll make um some
money a modest amount of money in uh in
real terms Peter Thiel doesn't spend his
time just thinking what everyone else is
thinking he fancies himself a contrarian
and as he thinks about how big Bitcoin
could be he's reinforcing the idea that
many of us are likely underestimating
not only how big but how important
Bitcoin could be for the world to see
Peter Thiel somebody who's been thinking
about virtual currencies for decades
come out on stage and explicitly state
that he still thought that Bitcoin had
100 plus X upside was absolutely
breathtaking for a room filled with 30
000 bitcoiners but price targets only
matter so much what was even more
impressive was that Peter Thiel
explicitly stating that he's a Bitcoin
believer that he sees the value of the
this digital currency and he thinks it's
an important tool for Humanity as they
pursue freedom in the coming decades
Peter thiel's a bitcoiner and when Peter
Thiel starts to talk about stuff like
this he's now trending on Twitter and
the mainstream media is paying attention
we're lucky to have Peter on our side
and I think that his point about
bitcoin's market cap reaching parity
with public equities is one that we
should all consider hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time